foreign
hi everyone I'm Elise Lampman and I am
sanskriti patnayak
and we're both customer engineers at
Google Cloud welcome back to the
Tactical series for startups where we
are creating a series of videos for
technical enablement to help startups to
start build and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably on Google
cloud in the last video as part of the
series we looked at how Google Cloud
helps you achieve faster analytical
queries on alloy DB today we will
discuss how to architect a blockchain
startup on Google cloud and how it can
help your web3 business grow as
blockchain technology becomes more
mainstream companies can benefit from a
more scalable secure and sustainable
infrastructure from which to grow their
businesses and support their Networks
but blockchain Technologies come with
their own challenges
ensuring reliable in performance hosting
of your blockchain notes
speeding up app deployment without
compromising security
fast and reliable Network performance
accessing large volumes of data quickly
and ensuring your data stays private and
encrypted at all times
Google cloud has its own strategy and
solutions that will help you address
these challenges web 3 companies choose
Google Cloud because it's fast and easy
to get things with a reduction in
infrastructure maintenance custom
tooling and operations blockchains
consists of transaction data that is
permanently stored and encrypted acting
as decentralized databases of sorts
instead of relying on a central entity
to validate and store data the governing
infrastructure of a blockchain is a node
a blockchain node is a device such as a
computer laptop or server that contains
a copy of the transaction history of a
blockchain
nodes on a blockchain from a
peer-to-peer Network constantly
exchanging the latest blockchain data so
that all nodes stay in sync
Google Cloud networking and compute
engine can help you host blockchain
notes on Google Cloud so developers can
build decentralized apps or D apps on
top of them
Dapper Labs the company behind some of
the world's most popular d-apps
including cryptokitties and NBA topshot
was looking for a provider that could
handle traffic that Peaks even with
Millions joining the network on the flow
blockchain
as part of flow's multi-node
architecture the execution notes
demanded high levels of performance to
run user transactions as quickly as
possible and at large scale
bringing low latency access for
developers and lightning speeds to
Consumer blockchain applications
flow runs their nodes on Google's
compute engine to ensure increased speed
of network and reliable performance with
large traffic enabling developers to
build decentralized applications at
scale as most major public chains have
official or community supported Docker
containers it becomes natural to start
looking at containers and container
orchestration to optimize resources
simplify operations Auto skill and
ensure reliable chains
using Google kubernetes engine companies
can support new protocols and scale
their existing clusters to build a
global infrastructure for their web 3
applications
modernizing with gke allows for
self-healing auto scaling and uptime for
nodes validators and staking
this allows for a more secure reliable
and agile way of developing your
blockchain applications
need a reliable blockchain
infrastructure provider look no further
than blockchain a valued customer at
partner
block demon offers a comprehensive Suite
of blockchain solutions including wallet
API and node management their platform
started as a simple three-click ethereum
node launch and has evolved into a whole
Suite of cutting-edge Technologies
including accessible staking liquid
staking MPC Tech and so much more
block daemin leverages gke to its full
potential by monitoring nodes down to a
container level and ensuring that they
remain in top condition
gk's Innovative Auto Repair feature also
takes care of management tasks
seamlessly freeing a valuable time and
resources for the block demon team and
their customers
compute engine and kubernetes engine on
Google Cloud give you fine-grained
control over the geographical region
your node is running
as of today Google cloud is available in
112 zones across 37 regions additionally
to location flexibility with Google
Cloud computes you have detailed control
over your networking infrastructure
including for example firewall rules and
IP addressing
Google's high performance private
Network connects blockchain nodes with
high throughput low latency
interconnects security and access
control are top priorities for us at
Google via our identity and access
management solution and Key Management
Service you can make sure to stay
compliant with access roles you give to
your users and submit an authorized
digital asset transactions using
encryption keys and signatures
and lastly Google cloud is the cleanest
cloud in the industry being carbon
neutral since 2007 and with the goal of
running our data centers on carbon free
energy 24 7 by the year 2030 as
announced by our leaders in our
sustainability policy roadmap
we understand that self-managed nodes
are often challenging to deploy and
require constant management and time
investment which can be especially
challenging for smaller teams that want
to focus on their Core Business
therefore let us introduce you to our
recently announced blockchain node
engine which is a fully managed node
hosting service that can minimize the
need for node operations
Google Cloud's blockchain node engine
can make these processes faster and
easier by allowing developers to deploy
a new node with a single operation and
specify the desired region and network
maintenance or test net for instance
users can quickly and securely deploy
dedicated nodes and minimize the need
for node operations
blockchain node engine also offers
security configurations that help you
prevent unauthorized access to your
nodes by placing nodes behind a virtual
private Cloud firewall only trusted
machines and users are able to
communicate with client endpoints
web 3 companies who require dedicated
nodes can relate transactions deploy
smart contracts and read or write
blockchain data with reliability as
Google Cloud actively monitors the nodes
and restarts them during outages
reducing the need for a dedicated devops
team
ethereum will be the first blockchain
supported by blockchain node engine
enabling developers to provision fully
managed ethereum nodes with secure
blockchain access
not just this by the end of 2023
blockchain node engine will be
supporting more blockchains
so keep a lookout for node engine which
will be out in 2023 to speed up and
skill your blockchain business
reach out via or contact us page to get
Early Access
now that we have understood how we can
set up our infrastructure let's have a
look at how we can use Google Cloud's
data and AI products to unlock the true
potential of your blockchain data
meets bigquery our data warehousing
solution with large-scale data analytics
capabilities
in the context of web 3 you can leverage
bigquery by applying analytics on the
blockchain
usually blockchains are open to anyone
but hard to make sense of
with bigquery your blockchain data is
accessible via familiar SQL queries
you can now find relevant answers to
your questions by querying whatever
blockchain data you are interested in
you can access blockchain data via our
public blockchain data sets
as of today 12 blockchains are indexed
in bigquery giving you access to full
blockchain transaction history data sets
these can be for example Bitcoin
ethereum Dash and more
to explain how bigquery has helped our
webkey customers a good example would be
nansin an industry-leading blockchain
data analytics platform nansin along
with Google Cloud provides web 3
investors with high quality real-time
Market intelligence allowing customers
to discover opportunities such as new to
Market tokens and analyze risk through
real-time notifications of significant
events and Trends in the crypto Arena
leveraging Cloud pop sub data flow and
bigquery nanson is able to store 60
terabytes of crypto trading data and
process five petabytes of data per day
which has enabled them to build queries
on hot D5 contracts tokens and nfts and
provide real-time analytics to their
users
with Luca Luca studio and bigquery web 3
companies can perform smart contract
analysis by combining and visualizing
on-chain data with other types of data
giving them a rich data-driven ecosystem
now instead of talking about all of this
let's jump into our Google Cloud console
and have a look at what we can use it
for in your blockchain apps
in this demo we'll make use of bigquery
to analyze some of Google Cloud's public
blockchain data sets these data sets are
available to the public via the
marketplace and are updated every 24
hours let's go to the marketplace using
the left hand side hamburger menu and
search for Bitcoin
then let's choose the Bitcoin
cryptocurrency data sets by clicking on
view data sets we can make use of it
directly Within bigquery
we can see that this data set contains
multiple tables
but what does blockchain data actually
look like in bigquery
for this example let's make use of the
inputs table
let's run a very simple query in the
query editor on this table
I will copy paste the query with which
we will query for address balances in
the data sets
let's run this query and after a few
seconds we should be able to see the
results
we can now see that we can obtain a lot
of information in almost no time we can
see here the addresses and the
corresponding balances of these
addresses
we can do the same for other
cryptocurrency data sets just by
searching in the marketplace or simply
by changing the name of the data
allocation in our query
this is amazing because we can now gain
insight into various blockchain data
sets in almost no time just by using SQL
we provide various other blockchains and
public data sets and here you'll see
some of the most popular ones
in the second example we can write a
very simple query which will aggregate
all ethereum transactions by day with
this we can get an idea of the
transaction volumes of the ethereum
blockchain instead of querying the
public data set over and over we can
also subscribe to them and Stream in
live transaction data this can be done
with the help of Google Pub sub creating
a subscription to the public data set
and writing the data into a bigquery
table
with this you can make use of the public
data and create live analysis or even
use the streaming data in your own live
dashboards
blockchain transactions are unique by
virtue it is not possible for
transactions to exist in multiple blocks
but there are few exceptions to this
let's uncover these anomalies with our
next SQL query this query will make use
of the transactions table that is
included as part of the Bitcoin data set
as a result of this query we can see
that there are two transactions found
that are duplicated within the
blockchain now how is that possible you
might think is there an issue with the
source data no of course not
so what's the catch you Bitcoin was
first built with Berkeley DB which can
handle non-unique keys after Satoshi
Nakamoto left the Bitcoin project a new
development team replaced Berkeley DB
with level DB level DB cannot handle
unique Keys causing the developers to
modify the bitcoin's source code by
implementing the Bitcoin Improvement
proposal
even though it's no longer possible for
a transaction to exist in multiple
blocks there are still a few older
transactions where this happened and
with the help of bigquery and SQL we are
easily able to identify these anomalies
we've seen a few examples of how you can
do analytics of the blockchain with
bigquery
but of course there are infinite ways of
how you can make use of this data for
your purposes whether by gaining
insights of transaction data or
combining transaction data with any
other data set you would like
and all of this just by using SQL how
cool is that
Google cloud has collaborated with
various businesses to build powerful and
robust blockchain applications and
solutions
cardia chain one of the leading
blockchain infrastructure providers in
Vietnam and Southeast Asia aims to help
millions of individuals and traditional
companies to integrate blockchain to
optimize their business Google Cloud's
easy setup and seamless Integrations
have allowed Guardia chain to accelerate
this mission of evangelizing blockchain
across Industries
with the help of Google Cloud's scalable
infrastructure leveraging Google Cloud
compute engine and Cloud SQL
cardiacchain provides services with
highest availability and smooth user
experience to businesses across
Industries
the company has also seen a 27 reduction
in their monthly infrastructure cost on
adopting Google Cloud
we can see how our Solutions help your
business build an end-to-end blockchain
application with products providing
infrastructure to reliably host your
blockchain nodes and Powerful data and
AI solutions to unlock the true
potential of your blockchain data
with that we have come to the end of
this video
all in all we have covered an overview
of Google Cloud's web 3 story and how it
can help you build your next blockchain
startup
we dived into Solutions ranging from
compute networking security and how our
data and AI Solutions can help you do
more with your blockchain data lastly we
saw a demo and wrapped it up with a
customer case study
for those who are Keen to learn more
please refer to the links in the
description box to get additional
resources
coming up in our next session we'll be
covering how to build Innovative machine
learning Solutions on Google Cloud we'll
start off with an introduction discuss
our feature products contact center Ai
and document Ai and dive into their
technical details we'll also see these
products in action with the demo and a
customer story
please like and share this video And
subscribe to the YouTube channel if you
haven't already
and don't forget to click on the Bell
icon to get notified each time we post a
new video
we hope you are as excited as we are to
get on board with this journey
hang tight and we see you very soon on
the other side
foreign
[Music]